if there is someone who I think is
awesome I will just build a relationship
with them and then the way I got really
good at Performance Marketing is I just
made a list of the top 100 best
performing consumer subscription
companies in the world and I went and I
sat behind the founders of grammarly
audible goop Robinhood Etc and I saw how
they bought ads and then I met Amara and
Thomas and Matt from yes Theory or Logan
or Jimmy and I just would study how they
created content and then I gotta go to
creating content and then I wanted to
know how to hire Engineers so I found
that ctOS of all the top startups and
I'd talk to them about it and I'd figure
out the process and then I'd implement
the process your top three goals as a
CEO is make sure there's enough money in
the bank set the vision and make sure
the right people are in the right seats